What would have been a cause for celebration...
...became a moment of grieving.
Prime Minister Fumio Kishida...
...and lawmakers from the Liberal Democratic Party...
...paying homage to the assassinated Shinzo Abe...
...before announcing the projected winners of the upper house elections.
Exit polls show Kishida's LDP now with a stronger hold on power...
...and a mandate to boost military spending to better counter China,...
...a key campaign promise.
Beyond that, a convincing result could also allow the government...
...to revise the country's pacifist constitution,...
...one of Abe's lifelong dreams,...
...a vision for a more secure Japan that resonates with voters.
Opinion polls show they favor greater military strength.
But inflation will also be high on the agenda.
Kishida has promised to enact measures to alleviate the pain...
...caused by rising food and energy prices.